ja das ist etwas was ich mit Professor
Volker Kronenberg jetzt im Studio hier
noch einmal analysieren kann guten Abend
Professor Kronenberg hat die musste das
so kommen dass die AFD jetzt diesen Sieg
einfährt weil die Politik nichts gelernt
hat es musste sicherlich nicht so kommen
aber wenn man ein Stück weit der
Denkzettel Logik folgt und das würde ich
durchaus tun dass viele gerade jetzt in
den Umfragen oder auch im Wahlverhalten
bei der nach wahlbefragung kennen wir
das ja das viele Wählerinnen und Wähler
der AFD den anderen den etablierten
Parteien oder wie auch immer wie sie
nennen einen Denkzettel aus
Unzufriedenheit verpassen wollen dann
passt das natürlich ein Stück weit ins
Muster wir haben es ja gerade selbst bei
den Stimmen der anderen Parteien Ampel
eben auch gehört als Selbstkritik die
Union man weiß sich das wechselseitig so
zu also insofern lag da natürlich eine
gewisse Kontinuität weil nach dem ersten
Wahlgang hat man sich da dann so
Wagenburg mäßig zusammengeschlossen so
ganz überraschen Hubschrauber war nun
dieser Wahl sich jetzt an dieser Stelle
hier nicht 10% sind feste fixe
überzeugte afd-wähler sagt man ja und
wenn wir jetzt bundesweit schauen ja
nicht die nicht jetzt Thüringen sondern
wir schauen noch mal bundesweit und zehn
Prozent ungefähr jetzt also 18 19
Prozent ist im Moment das Umfrage
Ergebnis ja für die AFD da sind weitere
fast genauso viele sind diejenigen die
sagen nee ich will jetzt denkzeit
Denkzettel geben also das ist aber doch
eine das ist aber doch eine Gruppe die
tatsächlich noch zu gewinnen ist wodurch
denn die hier waren die Vorschläge alle
schon auf dem Tisch und hat sie damals
überzeugt dass sie eben gehört haben
eher konstaniert ist dann der Hinweis
der Parteivorsitzender der
fraktionsvorsitzen wir müssen jetzt das
was wir auch schon länger also im Grunde
genau ja also im Grunde so schwer ist
das ja nicht das ist eigentlich ja das
politische kleine einmal eins das ist
besser kommunizieren das ist womöglich
doch weniger streiten und man einen
Gebäude Energiegesetz über Monate hinweg
wo man teilweise sagen könnte das sind
ja auch technische Details wir haben
hier im Studio gestanden gesagt am Ende
wird man im Grunde die Fristen
verlängern man wird das Ganze etwas man
nimmt den Druck raus so ist es auch
gekommen warum geht das nicht schneller
warum erklärt man nicht besser aber das
ist nicht nur die Regierung vielleicht
ist auch das durchstarten was jetzt vor
esken andeutet oder Fräulein wir müssen
jetzt sozusagen noch noch mehr Gas geben
vielleicht ist das nicht ganz im Sinne
eines Teils der Bevölkerung aber es
richtet sich sicherlich auch an die
Union an die CDU wo ist denn die
kraftvolle
Opposition insofern als dass man nicht
nur kritisiert sondern auch bessere
Antworten gibt ich glaube letztendlich
so kompliziert ist es nicht die
Unzufriedenheit über Monate hinweg und
das ist nicht nur die die Wärmepumpe die
ist nun mit Händen zu greifen und das
ist jetzt dazu führt ja das baut sich ja
eigentlich schon sagen wir mal seit
Corona auf diese Unzufriedenheit dieses
wir werden nicht gehört wir versuchen
unseren Punkt zu machen in verschiedenen
in verschiedenen politischen Feldern
also wenn wir jetzt mit Corona beginnen
dann jetzt sind wir hier bei einer bei
einer Heizung und einer Wärmepumpe also
es sind viele kleine Punkte also den
Vorwurf den muss die Politik sich mehr
als anhören sagen auch sie und die CDU
die kuschelt die versucht die Themen zu
besetzen ja vor allen Dingen wenn sie
natürlich die die Fallhöhe künstlich
auch so erhöhen also Ampel wir machen
das jetzt ganz anders und wir machen das
jetzt nicht so konfliktoriös und wir
einigen uns da anders und es wird nicht
mehr quälend lange Nacht Sitzung geben
und was erleben wir jetzt damit solche
nicht gesagt sein dass Politik nicht
auch sehr kompliziert sein kann der
Teufel steckt eben in den Details wir
müssen Verordnung umsetzen anderes mehr
aber dann eben besser erklären oder eben
auch reagieren ein Stück weit Druck
rausnehmen ein anderer Stelle flexibler
werden das ist im Grunde die Kunst das
Stichwort lautet Vertrauen Vertrauen
schaffen und erhalten in der Bevölkerung
und da sind wir bei ihrem Hinweis zu
Recht das Vertrauen ist irodiert und das
ist nicht nur eine Ost West Thematik
sondern das ist in in ganz verschieden
ist der Bevölkerung das ist das ist ja
ein Befund der auch besorgniserregend
ist wenn sie sagen der ist in
verschiedenen der ist bundesweite dieses
zerstörte Vertrauen wie tief greift es
naja gut das ist natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich dann doch fest zu machen
aber wenn wir uns bleiben wir mal den
Ostdeutschland nächstes Jahr die
Landtagswahlen Brandenburg Thüringen
Sachsen anschauen dann sind das
natürlich Alarmglocken und es reicht
jetzt nicht sozusagen nach jeder
Klatsche um das einmal so auszudrücken
zu sagen jetzt müssen wir es aber besser
machen also letztendlich ist es klar und
in anderen Teilen jetzt nehmen wir mal
noch mal Westfalen nehmen
Westdeutschland im ruhegebiet da kann
man sich nicht davon frei machen dass
wir das da auch natürlich erleben wir
haben eben schade waren Linkspartei
gesehen früher war das die Parteien im
hohen Maße von Protest Wählerinnen und
Wähler profitiert haben das ist jetzt
die AFD aber es ist kein Hexenwerk wir
haben eben schon angedeutet was was
gemacht werden könnte Aktion kommen
denn ein Beispiel Nachhalt Möglichkeit
Klimawandel nachhaltiger Politik das
stößt ja insgesamt auf große Zustimmung
in ganz großen Teilen der Bevölkerung
wenn man dann aber genau hinschaut sich
die Konflikte anschaut vielleicht auch
dann Fristen wieder verkürzt die die die
im Grunde das Tempo unnötig erhöht und
Ängste führt da sind wir wieder dabei
vertrauen ob berechtigt oder nicht die
Ängste dann ist das der Nährboden für
einen solchen Wahlerfolg wie wir ihn
eben gestern erlebt haben in diesem
Protest und Denkzettel sagt Professor
Volker Kronenberg heute Abend hier bei
uns im Studio bei Phoenix